bonjour je m'appelle jean sébastien
goulet et je fais mon doctorat en
administration à hec montréal
bonjour n'ira qu'en judalet fait nous
dans le torrent quand même dans des tons
coup comme dirait le grand maître
confuse en fait une blague que je vous
fais sa main de maître yoda dans la
version chinoise de la guerre des
étoiles quand il vous dit la peur mais
dans la colère la colère manhattan mais
dans la souffrance
la colère c'est un côté obscur du
leadership
c'est même l'émotion au travail qui la
plus dommageable pour le leadership des
managers c'est donc un phénomène
important étudie mais dans mon corps
tout a débuté parce que je voulais mieux
comprendre mes beaux parents sont des
hauts dirigeants en chine et j'ai
observé qu'il gardait leurs émotions à
l'intérieur il y avait c'était pas
facile de les faire parler
c'est pour ça que pour mes recherches
j'ai décidé d'opter pour une approche
méthodologique basé sur la
psychodynamique qui est une approche qui
permet d'investir il théâtre intérieur
d'une personne en la faisant parler sur
son vécu et ses émotions et j'ai donc
été en chine interview 40 aux dirigeants
chinois les pdg des ministres afin de
voir c'était quoi leur processus commun
avec lesquels ils gérer leur colère et
personnes avaient fait ça avant moi donc
je vous parlais de monsieur rang nous
serons il est très représentatif de mon
échantillon de manager lui possède une
très grande entreprise très prospère un
homme de caractère et pour lui être ami
avec ses employés comme tous les autres
que j'étais revenu et c'est très
important mais il l'a pas eu facile dans
la vie car il me confie que pendant sa
jeunesse lors des révolutions
culturelles et bien son père s'est
suicidé
et ça ça a été difficile pour lui parce
que donc du tout construire à partir de
riz alors plus tard quand son employé
monsieur bret fait une grosse gaffe dans
son entreprise le vécu de l'anxiété il y
parle de pas atteint ses objectifs pire
de tout perdre
arbitres en colère mais il part de sa
colère parce qu elles pourraient briser
son amitié avec monsieur bail
c'est pour ça que et a commencé un
processus avec lesquels il a pu se
dégager de son côté obscur avec la
répression lui a tout gardé dans son cas
puis c'est du pur rupo fera fort je
crois pas
je crois pas mais ensuite il ya un autre
mécanisme est apparue et ça c'est une
découverte culturelle que j'ai fait et
je les appelais la commisération
commissaire et c'est prendre en compte
les malandain en a fait un thème juge
envers ses erreurs ce n'est pas la même
chose que l'empathie comme on en connaît
le seront que ces répliques monsieur
bazin permanent il saisit dans sa tendre
je pense qu'ils étaient préoccupés
c'est pour ce que fait la guerre et ça
lui a donné le temps de calmer sa colère
en bout de ligne
ma recherche un même des contributions
pratiques importantes en gestion car
elle nous permet de mieux comprendre des
émotions des managers chinois avec qui
on fait des gros afin qu'à oublier pas
que la chine est le deuxième partenaire
commercial du canada
et vous trouvez pas qu'avec la
commisération son approche constructive
pour garder l'harmonie au travail est
ici avec un nouveau pouvoir de la force
contre vous allez mieux gérer votre côté
obscur